cat you haven't been on the podcast in a
while why don't you introduce yourself
before we talk about omni for an hour
well so I'm captain Alec I'm one of the
partners at YC I I work a lot on
outreach to applicants so everything we
do with an external focus at Y
Combinator and I help a lot of companies
in the batch with their launches I had
the pleasure of interviewing Omni at
least once yes one of the times she
applied to YC to send her the rejection
email but you know since then I've
gotten to see her go through YC and go
through the process that we'll talk
about today so I'm excited to be here
thanks for coming on the show
Avni you've been on the podcast before
but people who haven't heard of you what
do you do what's your deal
my name is Omni Patel Thompson I I
suppose was the founder and CEO of poppy
and what we did with poppy the mission
was to build the modern village and so
how I envisioned that was to find and
vet really amazing childcare providers
and then connect them to families when
they had gaps in childcare and so we
started that in my neighborhood in
Seattle about three and a half years ago
grew it and continued to build it out as
a kind of the testing ground for
something that could help the millions
of families across the country and
recently decided that looking at all of
the things the economics and everything
that it wasn't a viable scalable
proposition and so made the hard
decision to shut it down in December and
kind of going through the process of all
that last month this month and just I
think that's something interesting to
think about yeah absolutely so there are
a million things to talk about yeah yeah
but maybe we can talk about the
economics in the beginning I can shift
towards the emotions how you felt how it
went down yeah so at what point did it
become clear to you that this couldn't
scale because I think many people would
say like that's a/yc maybe even watch
the interview question mm-hmm like how
do you grow this thing to a massive
scale why did it take three years for
you to realize that yeah so I think it's
a multi-layered kind of question for me
at least in this space
even from the beginning I I knew that
parts of it were against the odds and so
what I mean by that is if you know the
category that I'm working within is
child care it's already an inherently
margin challenged kind of category so
what I mean by that is like what parents
are willing and able to pay for this
kind of work and then what caregivers
need to make the ones that are like
highly skilled and everything like that
so and then can you make some kind of
margin in between as a company that then
facilitates this stuff and so even from
the beginning I really kind of built
this company and looked at this company
as kind of this series of experiments
and so kind of like a mad scientist and
so in that vein I knew that we were up
against kind of challenging economics
but I always thought about it knowing
that we then took a look at pricing from
like a membership model and and
transaction revenue and I can certainly
go into the details of that but it was
always understanding that it was going
to be a challenging kind of category
it's not where things like travel maybe
the frequency isn't there but there's a
high ticket there's high average value
that you can make some good margin this
one had a higher frequency but you had
to then believe that you could also make
decent margin on that frequency so that
was all the like what the hypotheses
were based on one other thing that I
think is important to note is that what
it looks like at a certain scale is very
different than what looks like even at
the next level and so what I mean by
that is when you're doing 10 bookings a
week it looks like something with like
maybe three caregivers and maybe you
know 50 families or whatever it looks
very different at the next level when
you're starting to do a hundred bookings
a week and it looks different yet again
when you're doing 500 bookings a week
and so you know why did it take the
three years or whatever to really
understand that is because every single
time you kind of go through those kind
of step changes it changes and so to dig
into that a little bit further when we
started doing something like 500
bookings a week now you're talking about
working with hundreds of caregivers and
like thousands of families well that is
a very different thing than when I
started as like mom in the neighborhood
that knew every caregiver and like by
name and had personal conversations with
every parent
you have to look at everything as a
variable that you're experimenting with
but by necessity when we were smaller we
did feel like that mom-and-pop shop
doesn't matter that we were building the
software but it felt like that it felt
like you know we were an SMS based kind
of platform from the interface it felt
like people knew who were they on the
other side but again if you're gonna
look at scaling you have to think about
that differently right so now you have
to have a team that is going to be
behind the SMS you have to not
necessarily know every single caregiver
personally those have implications
because that changes the value
proposition where that caregiver might
have you know felt like oh I have an in
with like knowing exactly who the team
is and all this kind of stuff it changes
my work at a bigger scale it turns into
yet another kind of gig economy job
which isn't good or bad but it just you
know has an implication what when we're
looking at is that what that labor pool
wants to do is yet another kind of gig
job and so that just changed the
economics can you talk a little bit bit
about some of the experiments you tried
that made you optimistic about the space
and the work absolutely so lots of
different things first of all there's
tremendously talented people that live
within our neighborhoods and I don't
like I don't think I should need to say
that but folks who are teachers or
students or stay-at-home parents all
these folks my hypothesis was always
they do exist in our communities and it
is our job to not only find them qualify
them kind of say that they've been
vetted and then could do the connecting
part but we weren't making them we
weren't creating them they did exist in
the community and then anyways that was
a big hypothesis at the beginning that
we did prove was in fact true because if
it started to become that actually they
don't exist then that would have been a
bigger problem earlier on but no they
they were there and we created a
mechanism for folks who are otherwise
working at Trader Joe's and just had
recently graduated we had more than a
few who were pursuing like dance careers
but they were working at Trader Joe's to
make ends meet they then started popping
and then quit their Trader Joe's job
because it worked within their construct
of like dance was their first career and
their first priority but then they got
to you know live their second passion
which is working with kids well this is
supply that isn't on other
you know like here calm or any other
kind of marketplace so we were
unearthing supply that wasn't otherwise
in the category I thought that was
tremendously powerful because otherwise
we were giving access to people that
weren't working in the space so that was
a really positive and encouraging
dynamic and then other things were for
example we started running experiments
towards the end where we did a thing
that was started as a marketing kind of
community thing called bring back brunch
and so we partnered with a really great
restaurant that had a kids area and we
would have poppies there for a couple of
hours in the morning
on Sundays and parents would come and
they could enjoy brunch while the kids
enjoyed themselves under you know
supervision well the hypothesis there
was just you know Ken you know we're
trying to enable this modern village
where people can like parents can enable
connection and everything and kids can
just still enjoy themselves and so some
of these things were like really
successful kind of experiments but you
know again when it comes down to the
core of what we are trying to do which
is connect a large number of caregivers
with a large number of kind of families
against a number of different dimensions
that started to get complicated one of
the other things I started to get
complicated was that has a good in the
bad side which is people were very
skeptical that parents would be okay
with a range of different people for
their kids right so you know you don't
really care who your uber driver is as
long as they get you from point A to
point B and people were highly skeptical
that we would be able to solve that
because the their thesis was that you
know you really only want the one or two
people well we were able to successfully
get parents to a great range of people I
think the average towards the end was
like you know six to eight folks and the
reason was because we had my my counter
thesis was that you know if you have
standardization and you have a great
range of people actually it's amazing to
have your kids interact with a range of
different folks this person is a drama
teacher and this person is a nurse but
you know and that came to bear but in so
much as this population also is somewhat
transient in the sense that you know
they're doing this for some period of
time in between grad school or while
they're you know in the early days of
their dance career they
eventually move on has most parents kind
of know that proved to then be a little
bit kind of tricky because once you then
have them all moving on and then you
have like the number of folks that
parents want you know eventually again
over time you start to see how that gets
complicated we're in the beginning it's
like oh no this is actually working
quite well over time you start to see
different economics and dynamics and so
was that just a growing sense that you
had or was there one particular moment
where you're like you know what I think
we might have to shut it down no I think
I would say probably about a year ago
it's always something I've tried to be
mindful of yeah I do and I can speak to
this a little bit later because I think
it's really important but I've always
done monthly investor updates mostly
because I think it's important to have
that that discipline against myself as a
CEO to you know have to read out to
somebody else like the results that
we're seeing and all that kind of stuff
but also to be able to understand like
what are the dynamics that are going on
and then if other people are seeing is
that successful is it not is it growing
fast enough and that's all a relative
kind of thing and so throughout you know
the growth of poppy we've always been
solid like we've always been solid and
growing but to the point of like maybe
five to ten percent and that's not bad I
mean in fact like for some of these kind
of marketplaces that's really good it
wasn't though taking off in the ways of
like fifteen or twenty percent like you
know just like as earmarks on that and
so it is something that was in the back
of my mind you know for the last like
maybe year you know of just like trying
to understand what are the dynamics
going on and that just made made me want
to experiment more and more boldly now
the other thing I think is super
important is even from the beginning had
the mind towards revenue so we certainly
weren't profitable but we were always
making revenue and I think that's also
important because it was able I was able
to then take the little bit over two
million that we raised and have that
last over I think like three years and I
think that's just important because that
bought us the time then if we weren't
growing necessarily as fast that bought
us the time for more experiments yeah
and so that's the way I thought about
that the writing was starting to be
written on the wall and
for me I wasn't done with the
experiments right so I still thought
there was you know maybe we could do
poppy pool which is you know pair
parents or pair of kids together and get
a little bit of leverage out there and
make it cheaper I thought we could use
stay-at-home parents as another tier
because there are people that live
within the community and so maybe you
won't see the same amount of churn hmm
so while I still had kind of these
experiments and like hypotheses in my
head I wanted to live to fight another
day and run those experiments and so it
wasn't until the last probably six to
eight months where we started to
experiment a lot more boldly because it
was quite it was becoming quite apparent
then with the scale that we were at that
that vehicle wasn't going to necessarily
work and so we started experiment with
some of these other things but at some
point and that's also where runways is
necessarily a good forcing factor but
where as we started to dwindle down now
to like six or eight months of runway
that's when it really I will say that
that was a forcing function of having to
make some important decisions but I will
say it was always it had been for some
time consideration yeah and we can get
into it but it was at that point that I
was like okay no now we have to really
look at what's in front of us and what
are the different options but it's not
like it was a one day I'm like oh this
is completely different it was a slow
build it said you know as a founder you
can read data in multiple different ways
right anybody can and it was more as the
evidence started to stack itself up in
not what it is today but will it get
better or will it improve with even
further scale further investment all
that kind of stuff that's the real
question that I had to ask myself and as
it became apparent that it wouldn't
that's when it really was let's evaluate
this can you talk about that moment of
what what was the final moment where you
decided this is how I have to move
forward we have to shut it down I don't
know that there was there was a moment
and is probably sometime in November
where it was more the realization of I
don't think this is working the way it
is and so some change has to happen and
so for me I looked at it with sort of
three options one is because we were
still burning the money that we were
burning we could pivot and I think that
so hugely popular whatever like that's a
very popular option but what out of
would have necessitated is cutting
probably 75% of our team bringing that
burn really down low and essentially
starting again to make that happen
though I would have also had to shut
down the service so not poppy wouldn't
have had to stop but the service would
have had to stop and I would have had to
act like 75% of our team truth be
completely told that was my ingoing
assumption that that's what we were
going to do but that was like sort of
like option number one option number two
was get ourselves acquired and as you
guys know like it's it's it's a very
lofty and a very optimistic kind of view
that somebody's gonna ride in and like
you know I don't know throw us like some
money for like the things that we've
built and then also our formidable team
but it was an option and so I wanted to
explore that with folks that I thought
would be good partners that would enable
us to continue our mission just in a
different way with different resources
so I thought that was an admirable kind
of option to pursue and then the last
one was truly shut it down call it and
do all that and so for me I pursued all
of those I had conversations with folks
that I thought were interested in
acquisition or good partners I will say
this is an interesting learning through
that process is that these these CEOs
were very willing to get on the phone
they also showed me a kindness in the
fact that they knew what this call was
about and without having to like play
games around it very quickly in the
beginning of the conversation because
you're also like how do you go into a
conversation like this like I was
talking to my team like what are you
gonna say I was like I have no idea but
as you go into these conversations they
kind of know what this conversation is
about and you know a lot of them were
towards the beginning was like listen
this is really great to connect let me
just get it off like right right off the
bat we're not in a position to acquire
so you know if you want to do like
partnerships or think about some of
these things but now for me was a
kindness because if we could just not
you know beat around the bush and you
could really know what it is that I'm
kind of looking at and kind of say it
then that definitively removes that
option for me and that is I think the
biggest the
this thing for founder's is that you're
always trying to assess all the
information you have in front of you and
there are very few paths that get
definitively kind of shut down and so as
much as you're able to kind of do that
that actually helps you to go figure out
what the path is now that it isn't to
say that there couldn't have been
someone out there that eventually you
know could have done but also as I was
evaluating that that would have meant
you're having to continue to operate
your thing because if you're trying to
go for acquisition you're trying to go
from a position of strength and what
would it take to actually continue with
the team to continue to grow and all
that kind of investment as you're
ticking down the clock because again
runway and did I believe that we were
going to be in that ultimate position of
strength to be able to negotiate from
and again take off like the rose-colored
glasses and truly truly what is the
probability of that thing actually
coming through when the most likely
acquirers had already kind of said bowed
out it was at that point where I was
like if that chance is going to be like
less than like two or three percent then
let me understand that but keep it over
here but that's not going to be my go-to
I'm not going to be unduly optimistic
and run my company into the ground so
then I'm gonna have to go from a
position of like I don't have very many
options then it was the option of like
are we gonna pivot or are we just gonna
call this one and I think that's a much
harder question because I don't think
that there's a right answer I think it
was just the what was the right answer
for us I think the truth of the matter
is is if we had wanted to pivot we
probably would have done that you know
six months prior if I was going to cut
the team and leave a good chunk of money
and the in the in the bank to be able to
do that I probably needed more time and
so as I started to evaluate that like
which part of the team would I be
cutting and like what would it be
enabling and then more importantly
pivots as a lot of people know aren't
these magical things that just happen
right you actually have to have a
compelling idea that you're going to
then be putting forth almost again from
the beginning you have to be pivoting
from something right and as I was
looking at the probability of success to
do that successfully with the team and
with the amount of money that I had left
it was interesting Fred Wilson actually
wrote a post I want to say
like maybe the same week after I decided
I think it's called something like pivot
or die and in his point there was you
know a lot of people want the pivot to
work with pivots sometimes if they do
work they are still painful because
investors more likely than not didn't
invest in that idea
sometimes consumer companies turn into
like b2b companies and things like that
it's certainly not what the employees
came on to sign up for and it just gets
messy and it isn't to say that it isn't
a compelling kind of option and it can
work for a lot of folks but as I was
thinking about that before even having
read that a pivot was unlikely it also
didn't do if it if it didn't do right by
the mission of what we set out to do
what we raised that sum of money what we
got this team assembled for then for me
that's ultimately when I started to
consider is a better to cleanly call it
and not I'm not saying that any part of
that was easy but that's when it wasn't
like a morning that I said I think we
need to call it it was more that it
started to I started to live with the
idea of oh actually what if we called it
because even through this whole process
I still assume papi would kind of
continue even if we shut down this
business line or kind of product most of
me was like okay no it's going to be
okay because I'm still going to be a CEO
of papi and we're still going to figure
it out there was a day though right
around Thanksgiving that it became clear
that actually I think the right thing to
do is call it because we set out with a
hypothesis and we raised money on it and
we built a team on it and if that
hypothesis wasn't going to pan out the
way that we thought it was then let's
shut it down as well as we could
and start afresh yeah so what were you
communicating this all with your team or
you talking your partner your investors
because I think you know leadership a
lot of it is you know being optimistic
and excited about the future and you
talked about it in your article founders
living in the present in the future
right so you have to be excited but then
when you're facing this reality of like
maybe running of money it's not going to
work out how do you go about having
those conversations and who did you talk
to
yeah I think that's a really great
question um so for me even towards the
later months I think it's a hard thing
when you have when you start to have a
team that has striations and like you
know some folks are junior some folks
are like your lead team I learned the
lesson I I generally as a leader try to
be as transparent as possible even
towards the end our Investor update went
to everybody from the most junior folks
to my CEO oh I believe in transparency I
believe in educating people on what do
the numbers mean so even that very last
investor update every single person saw
exactly how much we had in the bank
balance and the default dead
you know headline it isn't comfortable
but I don't think we're not in the
business of you know being afraid of
uncomfortable right I wanted everyone to
understand the the place that we're at
the difference though was I had to have
a lot of these conversations with just a
couple of the folks that I on my lead
team that I deeply trusted with not only
the hard conversation but I think in the
beginning when we were only like three
or four people we would have
conversations in the open with em
everything what I soon realized as we
started to grow towards 810 people is
that I can talk about these super
ambiguous things but I also have the
power to do something about it
for more junior folks you have to be you
know what's the kinder thing because you
can certainly talk about transparency
and kind of tell everyone everything but
if they don't have the power the tools
to do anything about that that is just
that's in Zion evoking right like that
you're not giving them the tools to do
anything about it you're just giving
them information and then there's
nothing else there and so I tried to toe
the line also to keep in mind like if I
made the decision maybe the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving mm-hmm and we made
the final announcement on December 3rd
there wasn't a lot of time and I can
certainly go through that because I also
thought that that was important because
I didn't want to operate in a space
where part of the team knew something
and then you know we're also not that
big and so part of that decision was or
the decision-making process was there's
some folks that I trust immensely
everything from some investors some
mentors all that kind of stuff folks for
who with whom I talked and I told them
where I'm you know this is what I see
what are my options and you know even
after like only five or six kind of
conversations it really came down to
these things one what do I want to do
because the reality is is that anything
is possible there's a massive variety of
things that are possible but it has to
be led by what do I want to have happen
and so while that wasn't helpful hearing
it it was tremendously powerful in the
doing of it the reason is is because
what I ultimately realized is there is
power in choosing how this went down and
so even though all of this is painful
nobody made us do it
nobody there was nothing no outside
forces driving us to do it and so folks
that have gone through this will
understand what I'm saying but you know
when you can control the narrative when
you can control how this happens there's
tremendous power there but just to come
back to your question about like who did
you talk to and how did you do that
there was a short period of time where I
tried to collect information from people
I respect it had been through it all
that kind of stuff to understand
the range of possibilities then
understanding that you know what did I
want to do and it was becoming more
clear that I think it was better to shut
it down I did have conversations with
our investors because I think that was
important because from any sense of the
you know my duty you know just doing
right by their their investment and then
I at the same around the same time I was
also talking to the rest of our team and
so it was through that process that it
became increasingly clear that I had
made a decision and then I was
communicating it there was a small a
smaller number of people that I was
taking data from but once the decision
was made then it was about like it let's
communicator mhm so you got a bunch of
questions from Twitter and I think this
one could have been related to a few
things but Oscar when asked what was the
biggest hurdle you had to overcome from
investors and so on the topic of
investors I'm curious about like how
does that interaction actually go down
because that's definitely not talked
about you're the right medium posts
about like you know I'm winding down my
company it didn't work out but they
don't talk about this is how I you know
dealt
with my investors after I raised
millions of dollars yeah so I think I
mean obviously I can only speak from my
experience and from what we did I think
it actually part of it stems from how I
ran the company I believe anyways so as
I mentioned I've always done monthly
investor updates I think that in
retrospect was tremendously helpful in
doing this because I was completely
transparent about what was going on how
we were doing it how we were thinking
about things and the state of you know
how much money was left in the bank and
what you what their capital was being
deployed towards so if at any point
there was disagreement on what that was
being deployed towards like I was open
for that conversation so super super
importantly when I started to have the
conversations I shot out that emails I
picked up the phone to talk to them it
wasn't a surprise right like people knew
that this was coming it was it within
the realm of possibility I think where
it gets complicated is when this is the
same thing that I've always believed in
feedback to folks that report to you it
should never be a surprise right so if
you're trying to deliver you know hard
feedback if it's a surprise that's a
failure on you that's not a failure on
them and something similar here that
wasn't a surprise right because people
had seen like the economics that we were
battling the challenge is that the
status of the bank account so that was
one piece that was in retrospect really
really helpful for that hard
conversation but that was investment
that I'd made over the process then when
it came down to actually having that
communication I think that here's the
other piece I also I'm gonna say I'm
tremendously lucky or grateful for the
people that I have on my cap table but
that was also work that was also a
decision made very early that we were
only going to have the folks that really
believed in the mission and I can say
that that's really nice and easy to say
now but and I would like scrapped to get
that money together so I don't say that
lightly but it is in times like this
where it becomes so so evident that they
were and are a part of the team that I
was then reporting back and saying hey
guys like this is what's happening this
is what I've decided to do and I'm sorry
that this is where the story ends but
you know this is where it's at and I
will say I was
frankly surprised but pleasantly
surprised almost 201 everyone is like
I'm sorry because that sucks
but it's quite clear that you did
everything possible to you know take
this to where it needed to be and what's
next and I think that was also heading
into probably the hardest week that was
tremendously powerful to know that you
had the backing of the people whose
money you took and you were like I think
I I think
you know I have stored a stewardship and
duty to that but they gave me the gift
is saying no I understand like there's
times that this doesn't work and you did
what you were supposed to do I think
that's a really important point is that
we as founders have these really amazing
ideas of how we're going to change the
world with these concrete kind of plans
and then we raise money or capital and
we bring these teams together to go do
that well I did what I was supposed to
do right like I did all of those things
in a very transparent way and the fact
that it didn't work out the way that I
had necessarily thought that isn't
failure necessarily that's just you know
just a different way that it ended up
going and so that's my experience you
know I think being I think it's rarer
than you know having founders who keep
their investors so closely tided and
doing those monthly updates I think that
is so helpful throughout the process and
I think that's probably what in the end
made all the difference I agree with
that and I'll say it's like it's painful
it's hard when it's going well it's
super easy like I've got all the emojis
and the expansion marks and the bolding
and that's all really fun and when it's
not going well it's embarrassing it is
like I feel like I'm failing in my micro
kind of failures but because I held
myself to the standard that like you
know by the fifth of every month there
had to be a new not going out that in
many ways like saved me from the harder
conversations at the end because there
was transparency so like if there's one
thing like you know there's other
founders out there that just start doing
that if you don't do that right now
mostly because even during the time it
wasn't for the eventualities like this
it was because it held me accountable
for what I thought was like super
important so ya know for me from the
investor side I think doing right by
what you said off to do was the
ultimately the thing that people wanted
to see right course everyone wants to
see like the 10 X or whatever X returned
sure but understanding that that's not
going to happen for a great percentage
of the portfolio I believe that they'd
rather have the transparency the honesty
and like you know visibility and
absolutely and most of your investors I
assume invest in more than just poppy
you know like they're all over the place
so I've heard it talked about many times
at YC that when those updates start to
get a little bit slower a little
infrequent they're just assumed to be
dead so they kind of know the deal
anyway right right and so better that
because here's the other thing I should
hope that the vast majority of founders
that did a thing that didn't work out
you take all that learning and then you
put it towards the next thing exactly
well when there's the next thing you
want to then work with the best folks
and you want to work with the folks that
you enjoyed working with the last time
well for me to have a chance at
salvaging that I have to do right by it
right now right so again this is not
like perfect and it's like that's the
way that I just believed was the way to
move forward it's also a way that I
there's so much stuff coming at you in
that it's like a very much like a swirl
right so so I think as I was thinking
about how to make this decision I tried
to break it down into well who-who are
my constituents right so I have duty to
investors obviously and however do I
think about that I've duty to my
employees and my team and I deeply felt
that because that's the people those are
the people that you're interacting with
every day duty to my users right like
what is what does right by them and then
I think one thing that gets underlooked
as well but duty to myself and my family
right so like how do I kind of what is
right for me and my family and kind of
going forward and all of those things
are really important in making that
ultimate decision because the decision
to have poppy go forward in like some
different form or to be able to call it
in some ways had to do right by kind of
all of those folks so I actually wanted
to ask how are you so many founders
their identity gets wrapped up in their
company and so now that you know you you
know have you know shut down poppy how
is that making you feel how are you
doing right now and
yeah that's her from there yeah I think
if you had asked me three weeks ago
would be a different conversation I
think that's absolutely right
I started poppy when my second daughter
was four months old so for me poppy
isn't even just like a part of me but it
was a part of like my family right so we
had so much of it it takes up like a
presence within your life and so you
know part of it my identity is very much
a part of poppy in the last kind of a
couple of years I think the more
important thing for me is that my
passion for the space doesn't go away
even if poppy it isn't kind of carrying
forward it took me some time I think the
thing for me was that there is a there
was the the heat of the moment which is
that you have to make the decision you
have to act and so there was those like
months or like weeks that was necessary
and in that I didn't really think a lot
about my might and myself because I
don't think you can um and this is just
me speaking from my experience but I
actually didn't talk to any of my
friends I couldn't I had lots of friends
that were reaching out because I knew if
I started talking to them I would break
down and then I wasn't useful for all
the things that had to happen for our
users for our team there I think people
also don't know all the things that you
have to do right so when you send out
the little newsletter that says we were
no longer going to be doing this there's
still a tremendous amount of things that
have to get done also that's your choice
right but for me to do that we announced
and then we made a decision to do a
number of things to help our users so
that they could still connect with
caregivers on their own and kind of vice
versa to do right by that there's our
team so you have to make sure that they
are landing in good places and try to
see how you can help to make sure that
they have like good jobs that's
excruciating let me tell you like you
work so hard to find these amazing
people and then it breaks your heart
like a thousand times to hear how you're
gonna have to go give them up to other
people so that's painful and then
there's all the like the legal the
accounting the stuff like all that
litany of things that you have to go
through and so for a period of time I
didn't think about me because I couldn't
because I just had to like be sort of
robot and just go through the motions of
doing the things but there's also a
reason why I wanted to do this at the
beginning of December because there was
the decision of like if we're gonna make
the decision to do it
we can either kind of go forward for a
couple more weeks and we can be labor
and do it into January I thought using
the holidays was actually a really
helpful thing for everyone involved
because then it would be almost forced
time for folks to be able to take time
process all that kind of stuff and
figure out their next path myself
included and also if you're thinking
about in terms of runway right every
month that you continue to kind of
persist you're burning money right and
for me it didn't feel responsible to
continue to do that instead
could I repurpose that and say hey we're
gonna call it as quickly as possible
conserve a little bit of that capital
that might go towards like severance are
doing this as brightly as possible for
your employees not a ton but a little
bit of breathing room and so in doing
that then you know set the team up as
best as you know possible and users as
best as possible and then for my part I
literally just said I had to get to
December 17th that was my date in my
mind where I would then I would be able
to take a break we announced on December
3rd December 17th gave like two whole
weeks to kind of deal with all a lot of
things and then December 17th was you
know ok like let's take stock and I
think everyone processes things in
different ways I think part of the
realization and I wrote even a post
because like for me I write to process
things that it almost says like personal
therapy I think for me there's a
grieving process and I don't want to
liken it to like you know to people but
there is an in for me anyways like poppy
it was an entity it was like almost like
a living breathing thing that was with
me for a 4 years longer than any other
person was right and so there's a
grieving process that I had to be ok and
that's what other founders I will say
this the the notes that other founders
sent me on that day was by far the most
meaningful it isn't mean that like you
know so many people you realize how well
you're like loved and all that kind of
stuff with all the notes that you get
but the other founders really understand
the complexity of emotion that you're
feeling and so for me a lot of them were
saying you know give yourself the time
and the space to grieve it
to appreciate what it is and then kind
of give herself just the time to like
not consider anything and so that's for
me what the magic of like the three
weeks over the holidays were because I
could take time there was nothing I
could be doing on email or a slack or
like nobody asked me for anything nobody
liked any of that kind of stuff and so
to spend time with my family over the
holidays that was the best I think
healing I guess I could I could kind of
give myself and then there's a lot of
folks that will reach out and say hey we
I think we should go grab coffee and
like what's next and all that stuff I
also set myself a goal to say like I'm
not going to have any of those
conversations until like January 4th and
so like doing those little things gives
you then it's the same way that I loved
about YC when you're in batch you're
able to just tell everyone I'm sorry I'm
doing YC so like I'll get I'll see you
in 12 weeks right and it's a beautiful
kind of space that you give yourself to
then do nothing but this one thing in
that same way I kind of gave myself two
three weeks to say I am doing nothing
nothing that is going to be of anything
but is that that thing is just me kind
of healing and so that I will say I feel
I still grieve papi
like it's more than like jabs now right
so if I see like if I walk into our
offices which are still trying to like
you know wrap things up that hurts right
because you like all the memories that I
kind of associate with that if I see
something that's papi branded or
something or if someone talks about it
in good ways because we had tremendous
impact in Seattle and so now you know
people talking about like the in the
past tense but like the role that it had
it's it's nice but it's like turning it
to nostalgia but it's still there
because you can't take for granted
spinning up a company and getting it to
be a thing right like you can you know
none of us do or can and so part of me
there's like the doubts of like can I
ever do that again or will I ever do it
again
and you sort of have to like live with
those things also in so much as our nan
our society but like our you know we
have we try our accomplishments with our
our beings and our worth like you know
so so tightly you know for me going to
networking things or like you know just
those things it's complicated it's just
like oh so what do you do and that was
my next question it's like
cuz I know it's um unfortunate in many
cases that people just identifies their
job like this is my thing and people who
start companies even more so right
they're like I'm the founder when it
comes to your family do you find that
they care at all no also like it so is
interesting I was talking to a friend
they were saying like your daughter's
kind of get it yeah you know they're for
insects so no they only know that I so
it's funny they they're like but you're
the boss right
what is the boss okay like so that's
kind of cute um they don't really get it
um yeah here's the thing my friends my
husband like all the people close to me
my parents my brothers like they know
I'm not done right like so like for me
like and I think that's the bigger thing
that's the conversation I want to have
more broadly is that again it's a total
choice if some people are like this was
my thing I'm tired I want to go back and
do a different thing but for me
personally I found the place I'm
supposed to be working in and that is in
like the frontiers of like trying crazy
ideas out and spinning up teams and
doing that and so for me I'm not done
and so that's why also for me the way
that I think about this is that this is
what trying looks like this is what this
whole endeavor looks like it's a little
bit more messy and public because I
think a lot of folks go through these
processes of pivots and things like that
within the like private confines of I
raised a bridge round and I pivoted to
this product and I had to go through
layoffs like if you listen you're
actually hearing this narrative
everywhere like people are going through
these processes for me I'm choosing to
do it you know in this kind of way where
I had this hypothesis I raised a thing
and went to do it and now who knows like
what's the next thing so I think for the
folks who are closest to me they want to
make sure that I'm personally okay like
mentally and like emotionally and I
appreciate that
but I think because I still see so much
work to be done like for me actually
surprisingly I'm good like I you know
like after after three weeks of taking
some time and that isn't to say I'm like
rushing into what the next thing is I
don't know what the next thing is but
I'm not done right and so
what I hope also this conversation or
for other folks who are in similar
situations one thing over the last six
months was I don't know if I can shut
you it feels like a dead end it feels
like failure it feels like you know
investors are going to be super angry
users will never like love you again
like you know all that kind of stuff and
so I think it's an important
conversation to have that it is an
outcome it isn't the desirable outcome
not by anybody but it needs to be an OK
outcome because the more that we can
have this conversation the more that we
can be okay with it the more we can get
like through it and do it in as right
away as possible if there is that
because there are considerations as I've
realized there is a writer way to you
know if you think about your team and
what's next for them like they're not
getting any kind of financial thing I'm
like none of us are but if you think
about setting themselves up for the best
next chapter there's a right way there's
a better way to do that if you think
about investors and if you kind of know
that you're not going to be doing that
if there's a possibility of like you
know returning capital maybe again not
the outcome and not why they deployed
the capital but if that's the thing then
yeah sure let's go do that let's be
responsible with that and that that goes
with even like you know even for myself
like I didn't want to go through a
belaboured process under like on a Hail
Mary kind of belief that we could either
get acquired or do some kind of pivot
because that would have drawn into all
of our emotional stores as well in a way
that I wasn't comfortable with if this
was what the call is
again it's very different for different
people in different situations but that
was sort of how yeah yeah so I mean side
note I love the philosophy but not
stopping because of people that make me
most angry are the people that do one
thing and quit forever even if that
means do one thing and make money and
then they quit right that's like oh you
had so much potential and you stopped
forever the thing is like I don't know
what the arc of the timeline is but it's
certainly for me I don't look at what we
built for three and a half years was I
mean it was meaningful it was valuable
but more than that it was learning so
again this is like the way that I think
about things almost academically is that
my job was to
have a question put forth a test plan
and then you know push forward the
knowledge and the learnings in this base
like what are the what are the mechanics
what are the economics like all that
kind of stuff well I just spent three
and a half years and learning a thing
like in all the different ins and outs
to not continue with another hypothesis
is almost like not irresponsible but
like it's it's incomplete right yeah and
so for me and I'm not gonna judge any
other founder because I get exactly how
hard these ears are yeah and you know
with different sacrifices and things
like that but for me it's that if we can
have these conversations with more
fluidity between this like effort and
like the next then maybe the hurdle
between one in the next isn't quite so
bad yeah I just don't know why the myth
is so pervasive because like if you look
at people you know like Michael Seibel
or Justin Kahn or a bunch of these
people they didn't start one thing but
yet people think you just try once and
it works out and I mean I think it's
also it's also narrative on you know how
we think about I mean cuz but a lot of
other folks did try the first thing the
Airbnb and Amazon and Apple right so
again I don't think that there's any
kind of one way to do this I think the
other problem is how much money we raise
and I think it's an important point and
kind of think about we raised a
significant amount so I'm not gonna have
a great gratitude for like the amount
that we did raise but a little bit over
two million dollars there weren't
massive checks from any one of our kind
of investors and so therefore the
theatrics or the gymnastics I had to do
to like do right by that capital was
different right then if I had raised
like maybe 15 million from like you know
a couple of different folks I think it
just changes how people have to think
about of what they need to get back
right or like what what promises were
made and so again for me I tried to be
very careful about which promises were
made and then how transparent I was on
how I'm doing against them so I think
that allows certain leeway on some of
these things and I'm not saying like it
is hard like different people have
different businesses right like I didn't
have like capex and I didn't have like
these assets or I didn't take people's
like users money or things like that
because of the type of software we were
building
so different things are different but I
think you know as cleanly as we can keep
each try and then just say okay well
that one didn't work let's get on to the
next thing I think that's where you do
see the building right like if you look
at the folks like Blake's slack or
Twitter and like they are like this
notion of serial entrepreneurship it's
not that they just magically turned into
or even Pinterest right like it isn't
magically that they started on this
thing it's that they collected knowledge
in disparate kinds of things and tries
and that they finally put it together in
a way that really unlocked the big thing
right I'm still hopeful that that's what
I'm gonna do
I have faith so I mean yeah how are you
thinking about what's next I know you
don't have a thing you're not here to
announce like a venture fund but you
know you've learned a lot with Poppy
obviously you like the space how do you
start thinking about what you want to do
next yeah so I think even a part of you
know sort of like the three weeks to
kind of assess things I still want to
understand like what am i deeply still
passionate about what am i deeply still
curious about what do I want the work to
be and I let gave myself to space to say
it like it could be like anything right
I'm I'm deeply interested in books and
travel and like it really could be
anything because I think that's the nice
thing about this moment but I think what
it ultimately comes down to I am still
so passionate about the problems of
parents and moreover the problems of
like working mothers like me if I had to
pick like one person I picked myself
right like I picked the problems that I
and the friction that I still like
experience in the world in that I think
like millions of other people are and
again poppy was one hypothesis let's
build the modern village to provide
safety nets for these parents because my
parents don't live in the same town or
like whatever else it is that doesn't go
away so I think for me I'm still
thinking about what what do those
problems look like how might I want to
tackle it which piece of that do I want
to do but I think ultimately like I feel
that my life's work is in this space I
don't know what it looks like
specifically it does it start another
sure do I go work with someone for some
period of time to like again learn I
think the other thing that needs to be
understood is that startups are like
ultimately creative endeavors right and
so if you think about like artists or
things like that like you need to have
space and time to actually have
collected some kind of inspiration to go
off and do that right and so for me I'm
also trying to do disparate things like
I'm actually finally learning try to
learn how to code and so like I'm like
doing cooking classes I'm doing art
classes because and I'm having like just
conversations with other parents and
things like that I'm trying to observe
like go back into the space of like
observing and noticing like retail
spaces how are they concocted how do
people come together like those are all
things I'm super interested in and
without terrible judgement of like
what's it for I'm just trying to like
let it all sit and kind of see where it
goes because I think that was the beauty
of poppy that I learned which was it
came from an ultimate curiosity that it
was like a thread that I just had to I
felt compelled to keep on going and then
solving the next problem next I want to
get back into that space and until I get
to that bar of things I don't think I
think it's actually irresponsible to try
to say I'm gonna start another company
what it's going to be I don't know so
that's kind of how I'm thinking about it
I I personally can't see myself going
back to a big company I've done that for
a good chunk of my life I loved that
experience it is formed kind of like Who
I am and how I do it but I love this
idea of you know imagining a future this
whole idea of like imagine the future
and build what's missing I think that's
hugely compelling yeah I mean but we
talked about this on the last podcast
like before Poppi you're pretty tracked
person right like you had your fit you
got your fancy MBA you had your fancy
job you know you got yeah you get
married you have kids you do all that
stuff right and so now you're just like
I know you got to say I'm very
uncomfortable
I don't have to sit on my hands anything
it's funny because my husband was aiive
so when I said like I'm doing the coding
and all this kind of stuff I actually
realized I'm not someone that can just
do unstructured nothing like
unstructured like sitting on the couch
and watching Netflix and that's okay I
can be someone that needs to check off a
box and said did I do my hour of like
coding today and did I do my hour of
whatever because that for me tames the
like monster that says you're doing
nothing with you but still allows me to
continue to explore in a kind of a
productive way along some kind of
timelines so I have my like little
things like that it's also to be again
like if there's an overall lesson in all
this it's gonna sound really silly but
it's kindness because it's kindness to
myself to say I I'm sure I didn't get
this all right
but it's that it'll be okay it's
kindness to say give me space and like
get yourself this space to go figure out
what's next
it's kindness in saying what is the
kindest thing even though it doesn't
look like it to your team to your users
to not labour under false pretenses to
call it have super hard conversations
but then kind of move forward and so
it's really really weird but I mean
maybe that's why I'm like as whole as I
feel for right now but it's just that
you know leading with that that point of
view of kindness kind of gives you space
to kind of do these interesting things
so yeah I don't know I I missed terribly
my Annette can't believe I'm saying this
but like my 9:30 a.m. stand-ups right
like there was purpose there was like
you know everyone has to fire to like
9:30 and now at 9:30 I still I have to
shut off the slack notification but like
it's like you know join the thing and I
it's just like it's just little
reminders but now it's getting to a
place of like no no no I know I'm gonna
get back to that but there isn't a rush
to get there and so I think that's I
hope that that's what other folks are
just kind of like in similar areas I
hope the thing the thing for me is that
the one challenge is that yes I think
you could take a look and say poppy was
a failure I think in some lenses like
that's the narrative but I sort of push
back on that because I don't think poppy
was a failure
poppy set out to do and did
the thing especially for thousands of
parents and like you know hundreds of
different caregivers it did exactly what
it was supposed to do and it did
tremendously well the fact that it
doesn't go on to then scale and scale
was what I was interested in there was
also an option to say let's just make
this a nice high-end tech enabled agency
and folks were like why didn't you just
raise prices and do all that I could
have a hundred percent could have and
turn it into a nice kind of like side
business or whatever else it is that
wasn't my mission that wasn't my intent
and that still isn't what I want to do
is go find the solutions that work for
the millions of people and I was never I
never was like two ways about that right
and because and so some people have a
hard time understanding that especially
users which is unfortunate because you
know poppy could be still existing if
you know I had chosen that path but that
isn't what was true to me and true to
what I thought like our mission is and
so I think that's the thing that I think
we need to have more conversations
around is that as long as you're true to
that I think you have lots of leeway to
make some of those decisions because
yeah they're hard and there's no one
right answer but as long as you kind of
can articulate that I think it gives you
some space cool well this has been great
thank you have aney thank you
you